well I think being raised during the
Depression is a very important thing in
my generation I think it it meant that I
had to learn very early how to work hard
and how to be independent and so maybe
part of it is that you just learn that
you've got to be independent and that
the world isn't going to come to you
with all sorts of gifts
not very enthusiastic I my mother wasn't
even enthusiastic about according to
college but I had good friends in
graduate school who were very very
encouraging and I still retain some of
those colleagues through all the years
and they made a huge difference
early years it was a challenge to find a
position so in the early years I think
being a woman was a big handicapped
pursuing the kind of work i have been
doing was not very much appreciated
across the social sciences so but i just
got fascinated with what i was doing and
so being a stubborn son of a gun i just
kept going
well the trying to do really good field
work and then I was very fortunate I was
able after being graduate advisor during
the Vietnam War and 80 entering students
and a fair administrative load I was
able to teach my first graduate seminar
and I had outstanding graduate students
some of whom have become colleagues and
I work with all I have worked with for
many years and I then worked with
undergraduate students so that I was
able to blend research and teaching in a
very active way in Indianapolis studying
policing in black communities in chicago
again studying and policing and that was
so interesting that i wasn't so
concerned about what my colleagues
thought I just got interested in what I
was doing
it was a big controversy at UCLA in the
political science department they'd not
had a woman in their program for many
years and there were four of us out of
40 admitted in the year I was admitted
to a doctoral program and there were
many of the faculty who were extremely
upset but again I had many friends that
helped me through it
yes I don't think they are supporting
socialism as a top-down theory a lot of
socialist governments are very much
top-down and I think my theory does
challenge that any top-down government
whether on the right or the left is
unlikely to be able to solve many of the
problems of resource sustainability in
the world